[Music]
good morning John it's Friday July 6th
if you have a chance always watch
fireworks from slightly above and that's
why it's amazing to live in a town
that's surrounded by mountains
yay for American independence it means
that I'm on the even days and I don't
have to do a song next Wednesday nothing
I don't like doing songs it's good for
me I agree but it's hard and I'm busy
I'm so busy that I have to eat while I'm
doing brother a 2.0 because I don't have
time to do Brotherhood 2.0 today because
I'm going to be today tubing is what we
do in Missoula when it gets too hot
instead of air conditioners we just go
and sit in the river which is actually
extremely pleasant sitting on a river
letting it take you wherever wants to
take you that is probably my favorite
part of the summer possibly my favorite
part of the entire year so when tubing
season arrives just generally when the
temperatures have three digits in them I
am so happy to be able to hop into the
river do you see what these three
nerdfighters did when they said that
they made a sign that said nerdfighters
in their driveway I was picturing you
know regular-sized driveway turns out
that they have a very very big driveway
in fact it's probably the driveway for
about 300 different people who live in
their apartment complex and they wrote
nerdfighters coloring the entire
driveway we're talking about a
nerdfighter sign with every letter
roughly 10 feet tall also on their email
to us they said that some policemen came
by to harass them a little bit about
their use of the nerdfighter sign but
they stayed strong and they convinced
the police officers that nerdfighters is
indeed not a bad word nor does it have
anything to do with terrorism and they
were allowed to go free John I'm a
little bit confused about your decision
to declare email bankruptcy when we go
financially bankrupt that's a bad thing
like a really bad thing but you seem
really excited about going
male bankrupt in fact ever since you
heard about the idea you were really
into it and I'm afraid that you should
take it a little bit more seriously
going email bankrupt is a really big
deal in fact I'm gonna try and get you
on I chat so we can talk about this
face-to-face
[Applause]
hahahaha I just instant message to you
but the silver lining is that you
instant messaged me back so what do I
have the pleasure of your instant
message for the first time in seven
months anything I should walked away
that nothing I said dude you're so
punished which is clearly textual
communicating I don't know John I was
trying to get you to notice that I was
on video chat John we are very stupid
nerdfighters we're gonna need some
punishment ideas I'll see you on Monday